HUMANITARIAN AANIGHTS
LAW.
UNICEF SAYLL UNCLEAR
W N WERE KILLEOR
INJURED, BUT IT FEARS THE WORSTE
THE REGION AS  P
W T
T .
>> RteS IS WHAINS OF RSIBAONP BG
AROUND THIS CAMPJUST AITEERE WAH
BUDI'TAS THE
GRD DOWNOWN TO THECITY OCHERNIHN
IES.IER SHOWS US
ILEF
THE SCALE OF THEA SITO
WAS THE
PUSH TO GETOIT
SO HE'S SAYING THAT THIS WAS A
THE RUIA BOMBED  H, D  RUSSIAN E
S MY CELLAR, H
HE TELLS UAS
MBARDMENT
TO TEAR HIM. YEAANI CT HIT. DN
SCARY.S  MY PARTS A
E OSA  STILLMS AWAARISSAAR CV
>> WW LIVE A
FROMPRNE IA
PHYSICIAOCRS
GO T YOU WITH
KN'VE Y BUSY ANDGRATEFTA WITH U
HORRIFYING SCENES AT THE TRAIN
AIR T THAST STATION.
L
BIT NORTH AND UTRDTHT THE SAME
PLACES IN THE WESTERN PART OF
THE >>NDER
MS RIGHT A H
RIGHT NOW WE'REORKING
CLOSE TO THERO AND WN THRECH MSA
INF PAEN'RASPREPAREDNESS
WHICH IS WHEN YOU HAVE A BIG O
CAO A SEPAPLACE TORE THEY HAVES
SO ODOCTORS WITHOUARE  NOW.
SAYINGMANYRI YOU
CASEAN ACTUALLY DONE
KRAINIAN H AND T SKILL.BUE BEEN
DID FROM FLEEING MPO
SO THEY HAD T INJURYND TH WOUND.
BLAST
OPEN FRAUROFIMBSR S OREMTO
ABDOMEN.
T FOR WE TRANSFD
RE.D THE NSING TO EVACU F TO TH
DOS ARE WORKING ON.
GIVING MEDICALING CAREETNT CE ?N
UNIT LEVEL.
WEEKS WEG URTRAIWINSPORT.HOPE I
E TOE MEANIN
MIGHT NEED MIGHTVENTILAT OR EED
PRSU AND NO DOUBT ITT
ZE RESOURCES IN EACCI YOUAND WO
AND THE RAILWAY?
ANAT WE ANTASTIC COLLABORATION
HAVE AAM
WITH RAILWAYWE SAY
Y NGBASICALLEDR THACT'S
ONE THING.WE'VE BEENCL
RELATIONSHIPH TH  HEALTH IN A
HOSPITALAUN WE DEC
ONN OF PS E HO GTHERE AN P
LIST OT CAN E TRAVEL ORS  TRA
RECEINITAL T BAL
SOHIOR, ANN
WELLIZED ANDE'
COLLABOU'RE DOING INCREDIBLE WO.
STAFE WORKINATK
GIVEN THE HOALHEALTHRSEEMILAR T.
FIVEKSO THIS WLYIT
GIVINGOFAGEMENT ENT INSO, YES, E
ICALIE
THT --N
ACUATION WITTHE TRT ASROSS
G FOR INFL